we are now a couple of weeks uh into a
war between Israel and the Hamas
government of the Gaza Strip and we have
seen in New York City as well as all
over the country and all over the world
some
insane uh Speech being done on college
campuses at places like Times Square by
public figures by private figures and
things like that can I ask you how do
you how does cancel culture fit
into this is good or bad should uh for
instance among the right uh there has
been a call to uh say anybody who is a
member of an organization that signed a
letter promoting Hamas or or you know
justifying Hamas the most famous
instance of this is a letter from
Harvard where 30 plus entirely Israel's
fault yeah that you know they are
entirely to blame is that cancellation
if you say anybody who is uh one of a
member of those groups should never work
again is I mean is that a form of
cancellation or is that legitimate is an
accountability culture accountability
culture um I you know I've been on TV
talking about this and I think it is
still cancel culture I mean just the
fact that it's um cancel culture that
many people agree with doesn't make it
not cancel culture and I don't like
black lists I I I like to actually deal
with people individually find out what
they really think about something you
know give the benefit of the doubt um so
cancel culture is always about now to be
clear do companies have the legal right
to hire who they want yes and and I
oppose laws actually saying that they
have to hire um but I do want people to
take a deep breath take go take some
distance and say to themselves what if
we lived in a country where every
company was also not just a widget shop
but also a political shop and the boss's
politics decided who got to keep their
job and it's not that fanciful because
that's what it started to look like in
2020 and 2021 where people were getting
fired for just having you know mildly
critical BLM uh statements there was
huge amount they were being fired for
supporting BLM or being against BLM for
for for being even mildly critical in
some cases like we we saw huge numbers
of cancell I what happened on campus was
insane in 2020 this year like we've
never been as busy as we were uh during
that so I want people to consider what
the world would look like if essentially
you have a f First Amendment but you
can't have a job if you actually
honestly say you're a political opinion
I will give one caveat though to the
Harvard students um I think that a big
part of the problem we have as a country
is that we too reflexively hire Elite
college
graduates I think this creates serious
problems and I think you should try to
find out when you're hiring from Elite
college campuses is like okay no I
understand you have a view that I find
abhorent can you work with people who
disagree with
you and what and what I'm hearing from a
lot lot of employers is not only are
they not really clear if these are
actually the best and brightest you're
getting from these schools um I was
about to say anymore but they never
really were um but Le less less
accurately than it used to be but
they're also potentially getting someone
who will show up and demand that you
fire your you know mildly Republican it
guy because they can't they can't stand
his point of view and credit where
credits du Greg actually walks the walk
and in order to hire me to be a fellow
at fire he changed a rule that he didn't
even realize was on the books that
required people have a college degree
and I think that it's really important
for people and employers to realize that
there are 4 million fewer college
students today than there were a decade
ago there are a lot of kids who are
actually going off that trail because
they think they can tread their own path
or because they've seen kids graduate
with degrees in feminist dance Theory
and hundreds of thousands of dollars in
debt there are very few feminist dance
Theory Majors let's be honest but um but
I think that there there are a plurality
of these young people who are genuinely
determined to pave their own path and I
give credit to employers like Greg like
IBM like Tesla like Google who are
dropping degree requirements and jobs
where that's appropriate to to broaden
out the the pool of possible applicants
to kids who did did take a different
path and didn't get mired in this o
liberalism